hi everyone just wanted to let you know
this time it's my fault which doesn't
usually happen for the record
uh i screwed up my audio tracks so this
episode is going to sound a little bit
robotic
um in some places i got a new microphone
and didn't realize that uh
it was doing something very different
with the settings um so here it is
sorry about that this is a this is
let let me and troy explain breasts to
you all right
i'm gonna do this you don't know what
you're talking about um
let me explain
i i have i have witnessed firsthand
the one of the powers not the power i
want to be very clear about that but one
of the power what are the demonstrations
of how
women are vastly superior to men
in an ability of of strength
and control um and so by and large that
doesn't mean men are weak it's just
that evolution has decided
that or i i can't wait for austin to
type it on this because we have great
conversations about evolution
yeah um the fact that
women are
he'll tire himself out and he'll just go
to sleep
um but no by and large like men
understand that we are just especially
in our 20s and 30s we are so
horrendously susceptible to the
every whims and waves of of whatever
opposite sex
um or or whatever sex we you know people
have a proclivity towards
we'll just do anything um for it and
therefore it becomes a threat
at some point like ah you're trying to
weaponize that you're like no it's just
my body
yeah that's definitely the perception i
have is that again
because before recording people take
having boobs
as you trying to steal their money
oh seduce them when
the reality is the boobs are just there
um
yeah it's it's has been someone for
having
you yeah and are just there anyway
it's not like i yeah i strap my boobs on
and then
walk out and i'm like gonna ruin it you
have different you have different boobs
for different occasions right different
boobs for different objectives yeah
which is half true because you wear a
sports bar and they kind of disappear
and i do strategically do that sometimes
but uh oh okay if you want to
say strategically in boobs that's the
problem
you can't make it in the sports bra what
about how much am i supposed to run troy
but you're but you're saying no no
that's
that's not strategic that's just
practical okay
fair that's fine there's a difference
right yeah i love that this is how we're
starting i also love
that i know the kind of day that mike
has had by his choice of beverage
oh what kind of day has he had my hair
is just lazy it's getting
massive yeah i had a very relatively
chill day so i had time to prepare the
coffee that's what you're saying right
troy
and then austin's facial hair investment
i don't know but you noticed
you noticed alana that shows like you
normally you know is that
is that what you said a second ago you
made some comment i started looking to
see if i had a tech problem going on
no it's that you have a lot of stubbly
you don't have none you just have a lot
less
it well because we're recording yeah
because we're recording
later in the week than normal um
there's an almost no no no there's an
almost two week gap
since i shaved normally you would have
seen me only a few days in
and it would have been like what
prepubescent child has replaced him
because uh yeah i i just i like that
this is not a show about judgement we're
here where your friends are still kinda
yeah we love you and i both like you
i know where your friends
ridiculous your hair yeah also i've got
all these people on my twitter timeline
who are basically thirsting over how you
looked during the game awards
uh there was a tweet thread that was i
didn't see it
that was how the [ __ ] is troy baker 44
and all the replies were
what and then somebody said the only way
you could possibly
be 44 is if you've made some kind of
awful deal with the devil
terrible what have you sacrificed to
make this that was episode 10 of this
podcast was the uh was the awful
faustian thing
absolutely i must do all of the game
yeah ryan wyatt hit me up and he was
just all these there was like a single
pump just laugh
he was just like ha look at that nathan
grayson [ __ ] up the troy bates needs
to look like this at 44.
it's like it's very good i didn't do
drugs
there you go all right future looks
bright for me have not done drugs um
and on that note hi everybody all it
takes all right we can do that soon
are we gonna get into it i guess we are
this is professional this is great
yeah um stalled out once we were
excited about that wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait you have to change your intro
alana get out of here
i i should have a video game writer
before
i do work for her oh well i don't
technically have to do it but sure i
work for sony said
so i did also and then i had to follow
up with
sort of legal and i was doing it more
than is necessary i only need to do it
when i'm speaking on something that now
it's just posturing
direct uh showing
that's why i don't want to do it too
much because you like it you're like at
starbucks and they're like what
what are you what do you have today well
i'm a writer
[Laughter]
i am generally interested uh genuinely
interested to see like some of their
response to this is like people are
already memeing it because i encourage
them to about how much i'm going to have
to do the disclosure oh my encoding
overloaded come on buddy there you go
um and it'll be interesting to see if
the audience who
demands disclosures from people also it
ends up being the audience who gets mad
at me for saying it too much and accuses
me of bragging or whatever i'm like i'm
so
interested to see if there's even the
internet might be hypocritical
i don't i suspect so who is the audience
of demanding disclosures i
i love that that's like the hall of fame
you don't remember gamergate
but i but yeah but i which a lot of that
part of it
i actually get there are like i do think
people don't disclose necessarily as
much as they
should certainly none of those people
deserve death threats for it but we
should probably do a better job
in a lot of cases but yeah i would say
they definitely used a good excuse
at places but i was under the impression
always that that rep
that was like essentially a scapegoated
oh yeah it's a minority yeah is that a
word scapegoated
i love it probably well it is i like
this now he's going to
yeah yeah i'll allow it i definitely
didn't coin that though for the record
full disclosure
thank you i have heard that word give
your disclosures until they get mad at
you
i really think it is going to happen
they're going to be like stop bragging
you're just showing off and i'm going to
be like hmm
interesting i do have you need a beard
um
take austin he doesn't have a hormone
problem you know that i have i have my
beard is shattered into a million pieces
in the
in the drain of my sink of 10 days ago
well you still haven't i don't know i do
not shave at the studio
so no that makes sense i remember
watching a movie once where it was
something about a a a woman says
um he leaves his shave leavings in the
sink and it just left it in double the
rails like
i'm not gonna do that no a lot of water
in the drain like somewhere
there somewhere you know in the system
i put the t the cap on the toothpaste i
i squeezed from the bottom
yeah but troy nobody ever worried that
you wouldn't have like
perfect hygiene etiquette so yeah
there's like you don't even need to tell
us it's not big you see that yeah
i think it's more realistic that troy
has a pee wee herman style machine that
just operates on all parts of him at all
like in one go
i'm pretty sure it's attained
yeah i sentience so too this is leftover
from last night this is
guys there's not much happening it's
just i finally got a haircut that's what
you're saying
actually i was able to no we're seeing
like seven inches of hair above your
head that's what we're saying
i know this is like something that i
find very interesting that i don't know
if other people do uh fifa for
21 or for the update of fifa 20 have
changed their hair physics to some kind
of like strand based
hair physics um and i've always found
half physics in video games to be really
fascinating because i know they're
really difficult
um i have a meeting with someone at the
at santa monica studio who works on
physics and i was just like
tell me about all of these things
because this is amazing and he was like
really and i was like genuinely anytime
you want to explain physics to me i love
it
oh brakes and vaults too right those are
those are super
i understand that glass breaks and
vaults because there's a lot of physics
involved in both of those things making
them look realistic
like the vaults in uncharted 4 were
supposedly like
or a watchdog apparently had really good
vaults i remember bruce straily going oh
man those vaults look so good
what somebody uh somebody when last of
us
part two came out i remember seeing a
tweet from somebody that said something
like
this uh this should win uh
this should win like art direction or
tech of the year for the
sh there's a shot from behind um
i think it's i think it's deena helping
ellie take off her shirt
and it's like the way just the the shirt
is
perfectly behaving like a real shirt
over a human body as it
comes up off over the it was like you
know astonishing
that's that's people you you don't see
it because it's so
normal and mundane but the tech involved
is yeah is truly next level also
that is here's what's crazy about that
that is
a vest made of rope
with no markers on it so
what they're actually watching is
there's four cameras typically on on a
set that are
there to just kind of be video reference
vid ref
okay are you hearing the talking in my
building was that what did it oh
are they fighting the couple are they
fighting is that the fighting couple
i don't think so i think unrelated yeah
let's get them in let's get them on the
show again
daphne and craig what are their [ __ ]
names that seems right yeah
sounds about right um but they in craig
the the rejected revell ballet so like
the backpack
is a rope with uh a netting on the back
that has weight to it
um and like shirts and stuff like that
are
basically just ropes that um
i find they're fast their conversation
vastly more fascinating than my own
right now oh my god
i take that personally since i got us on
this subject yeah i just wanna know if
they're gonna break up
i feel like they're gonna break up right
now and i just don't wanna i don't want
to miss it it
is the guy who lives across the way but
he's talking to another man he could be
talking about her
yeah i'm gonna diane it was diane it
wasn't craig
no so basically zero out of two sorry
maybe it's a different yes but anyway
it's it's to me what's fascinating about
the fact that you notice that is
is all of the different steps that it
takes in order for that to become
a real thing that means that someone has
to look it's so there's
there's no baseline other than i saw it
once and that to me is fascinating
like if you were making that kind of
thing like i feel like maybe this is a
bitter question
um of course i know
if you're taking like an item of
clothing off and you need to animate
that would you not will you demonstrate
for us yeah well
would you not use a bunch of reference
images
or footage or like how what's the
process for
for just something that simple so well
it's a tough one because it genuinely
like there's it's not done usually
because it's just such a complex
physical
like interaction because what what
you've the problem with any physics is
it's always simplified in a computer so
when you're when you're throwing a rope
around in last of us if you look really
closely at the rope and this is
great the rope in the last of us too but
if you look closely you can see it's
made of like little
rectangular pieces right it's you you
can see the polly's you but like a low
poly you can see
and that's because it's really expensive
to do physics so you try and cut things
down to like very simple versions where
characters ragdolling it's like a sphere
on a cylinder ultimately with
with graphics drawn on top of it but
ultimately the physics are very simple
the problem there is if you're doing it
with clothing if you think about how
many
points of contact a piece of clothing
has with your body that if
if they didn't if it wasn't a com a high
resolution
uh physics object it would just click
through and you've also we've all seen
like the you know the assassin's creed
style bugs where things are just like
clipping through surfaces on face
bodies and stuff so what i suspect with
last of us two but i didn't work on it
so i have no idea
i think that's pre-rendered i think and
what i mean when i say that
it's not pre-rendered in the sense that
i think most people think of
pre-rendering which is
um that it's like you know that they've
rendered off the footage and it's a
video that's playing
i mean the physics is pre-rendered
because what you can do is you can run a
physics simulation
slowly on a very you know on a really
impressive computer save
off the motion of all of those points
similar to making mocap but make
physics mocap in the computer
essentially and then you can bake that
one
back onto the surface i think the most
kind of well-known example of this was
in um
it's in one of the episodes of half-life
you see like a bridge explode
and it turns into a thousand pieces and
back in the day that was like
technically like amazingly impressive
and what it was was they pre-baked all
of the
physics of that all the motion of that
they they'd save that as a file
and then yeah and then they play it
forward for you you know
in real time in the game so that would
be my expectation would be that that's
actually a physics-driven
animation or a very high resolution
hand-made animation which would require
the kind of references you're saying
you're taking a lot of shirts on and off
in order to like film yourself doing
that
but then that's played out in real time
kind of
cleverly on on the surface that would be
my guess of how it's done but to be
honest like i mean obviously the guys at
mollydog are
two generations ahead of indies like me
so they may there may be a better way of
doing it now than i would
think to do it's an interesting thing to
ask though
next time i'm let's find out that'll be
a good one to know how they did that i'm
sure that someone's done that
someone's done like a gdc talk yeah what
do you want to do you want to ask them
how they did the shirt
i want to know how the show was done i
love that are you are you
drunk you're texting neil yeah ask him
was it pre-baked physics was it hand
animated okay was uh dina taking off
ellie's shirt
he's gonna start to get an internal
clock sense of when we're recording this
show
this is dangerous yeah this is playlist
listen isn't it yeah
okay check it out exactly was it was it
pre-pre-rendered
physics real-time physics
or hand animated my hope is that you
never actually told him congratulations
or something else that i've noticed this
is the first time this is the first
message and by the way bailey giving her
uh acceptance speech seemed to be
getting text messages during and i was
like that's got to be people
congratulating her
like i love that
[Laughter]
yeah honestly a lot of awards for the
last of us last night which wasn't
surprising for anyone
um i don't think how many did they end
up winning troy i feel like you probably
um i've got the list up right right here
um
so i was as i was driving down to
um the studio uh yesterday
where'd they shoot that by the way yeah
i didn't want to ask you a bunch of
stuff about how they handled that with
kobe
you know what excuse yeah i got to see
jeff keely and we bumped elbows
like 20 20 weirdness
i noticed them but i didn't ask them
because it didn't surprise me
yeah um i
i gotta hand it to him man i
i think it was his best one and he's
worked really really hard every year
and he's eaten a lot of [ __ ] um for
just trying to accomplish what he wants
to accomplish nobody liked the shik
robot
nobody jeff didn't like it but he's like
if that gets me to be able to do this
then great and he trades a bunch of
moments that even he's kind of like i
don't want to have to do that but
if that gets me you know who pokemon go
stuff last night i thought was really
stupid
as someone who loves pokemon go there
there was there was some kitchy stuff
and
there was a lot of stuff that was bought
and paid for it but it's like this i had
an ad in there
what am i talking about yeah we need an
anti-vaping ad
that's dope um i would have signed up
for that too as someone who used to vape
uh suck a robot stick as as colin
farrell put it
um the i walked in and i see
he's using digital scrims which i've
only seen used on a show called i
i miss right before you have to catch up
on what scream is troy
so scrim is a theatrical thing and it's
a
normally it's just like a a piece of
material that is used to kind of either
like it could be like gossamer white so
it's like
obscuring some backgrounds or it's like
or you can use like to bring
um a low if you don't want to do it's
kind of like what what mike's talking
about doing as far as like
there's some uh backgrounds or whatever
that don't need to be super
either interactive on a theater if
they're doing another thrust
so you can just like do like you know
florence in
you know or verona you know in as a
scrim
and then the balcony would actually be
something that's practically built
right um so there was a there was a show
called cages
um that had a cast of dozens
but there were only two people on stage
and i think that really caught both of
us by substantial sub
surprise i mean we we both kind of went
in austinite was our date night
and we went in to see that and i was
like this is going to be this is
probably going to be shitty because it
it's like it's immersive
theater it felt very off off broadway
going in yeah
where you're like this is this is
all power to them we hope for the best
uh i've never seen a play i didn't like
i have sounds like you have
discriminating taste
that's the wrong way of phrasing it i've
never been to the theater to see a
player and not enjoyed my experience
would be a more accurate way of saying
i've never not enjoyed the experience of
watching a play at a theater i've
thought some of the plays were bad
but i've always enjoyed going it
definitely elevates doesn't it it
definitely feels because of the
electrical the crowd
like the the set design always anyway
that was massive could go
did i get that right austin there was
two people on stage that's it
i think so um so they did the rest with
like projections of people
and it was incredible incredibly well
done it was there were there was a cat
there was a core
character in the show that was never
physically on stage and you completely
forgot
very quickly because it was like there
she is she's just real
and they're interacting with each other
and there's there's like practical
assets that are being moved back and
forth between the projected and the real
it was and they did a really good job
with the lighting to move your eye where
they want you to look where like
a character gets into a boat and you
don't really
see what's going on but then they they
almost are levitating
and like this the ocean line of their
boat is you know
halfway up where they would be if they
were standing on stage so they're
they're on some physical thing that has
lifted them up but it it just they just
transitioned seamlessly in
game i'd love to see this done with like
interactive real-time characters and
stuff
we immediately first of all they had we
found a place that makes
incredible tacos that's where i miss
those tacos
and i was like we wanted to go back
immediately we ended up hunting down
there was there was a guy that was
walking around
and uh was like picking up cups as
during intermission and stuff and just
kind of cleaning up
and um i was like hey man uh do you know
like anything he goes yeah this is my
show i'm i'm one of the producers on it
i was like
what he was like yeah you guys having a
good time or like i have
so many questions and i was like first
of all how much of the music
i can't believe that i asked this
question over austin is like how much of
the music
is live versus um somehow being piped
and pre-recorded wherever it goes
it's all life yeah that was the other
thing worth mentioning is the show is
essentially a musical
um and very produced
that's the thing that was what made that
so surprising is it was it was not
it was not like a guy on a piano and
singing
i mean it was like think of think of you
know
a a modern pop song that has
where you could just hear just a
thousand hours worth of production
to to to it had a very yeah musically
had like a very hedwig
kind of feel to me um uh very
it's fair do you guys
and i don't know what happened to them
because they were we we saw it kind of
early on
austin found these tickets and he was
like we're going to the show i was like
okay
and so we went and they were they were
kind of like an early
they were in previews but they've been
deving the show to steal the term
for years and they just have independent
investors and so the the whole reason
why i bring that up is
that's the only time i've ever seen a
digital scrim being used
oh the other thing worth saying by the
way is that the whole show
the way they did the lighting is the
whole show is black and white
uh right and you forget that like they
light it so well that even these
physical people on stage in front of you
you don't see any color ever it
but this is fascinating yeah you've
given me like one more bit of
information and i'm like what
it's it's one of them i forgot about the
black and white uh it
just looked it up and i i had that
flashback as soon as i saw their poster
images like oh right
i want to see like a batman noir stage
play in this exact style [ __ ] yeah dude
this this felt kind of like um it was
very impressive what am i thinking of uh
liberty snicket
kind of that aesthetic um very
um kind of gothic yeah
dystopian is that absolute is it
absolutely no smirnoff commercial where
it's like a little
motion black and white puppets and stuff
yeah it felt like tim burton did a play
it was super rad but what's the scrim
so so that so the scrim is is that's the
screen you project onto
yeah okay okay got it but what what but
they have some
that are they have some that are not
they're not opaque like a
like a screen screen so you can have an
actor acting behind it
right with the projection in front of
them so that
there there's there's a projection of
like another cast member between
the audience member and the physical
person on stage
is that that's how they do those
holograms right like in like
live shows and stuff is that basically
the yeah so what's a digital screen you
said
so is a digital scrim like a projection
onto that
digital projection onto one yeah so like
if if you were looking at the stage like
when sydney was up there when jeff
fakely was up there on the stage or
whatever
you saw like the big video wall thing
that was happening behind them
but when christopher nolan was up or
brie larson was up or the um
nominees were up that was a digital
scrim so all of a sudden they'd just
appear and it was like but they could
shoot it practically if they wanted to
so like when
you know uh keeley was in a cage that
was really cool it was in like this
yeah ball like it was really neat but
like when keeley turns around he's
talking to christopher nolan christopher
nolan's there and then all of a sudden
he just goes away and there's no
screen there's no empty screen there and
the fact that like the the baftas this
last year um
and i i don't mean to disparage anybody
there it the the fact that
first of all i i love what bafta does
and bafta is
constantly trying to iterate and improve
um
they do more for the industry especially
for
young developers independent developers
kids than anybody i'm a huge advocate
for what bafta does
they got thrown into how do we do an
award
show before anybody really had a chance
to
dev and and to kind of like experiment
to see what it was like so they did
pre-recorded
um acceptance speeches and everybody had
to do a pre-recorded acceptance speech
in case you won play the video package
and then move on i had to
record mine for the game awards did not
win
thankfully but we did have to submit
ours because of scheduling issues with
that
nominee category and the one thing that
um
i prefer about them bring being
pre-recorded uh which was still very
weird because like what i did was
basically have uh i think i had my mom
on the phone and i was like just tell me
that i've won so that i can react as
genuinely as possible to this happening
very strange 45 second cutoff like very
odd
but for the people who were phoned in
live um i think it's especially weird
for
a studio like sucker punch uh at the
game awards who weren't nominated for so
many things they have to be on
call the whole show and just kind of
react and clap
um if they haven't won and i feel like
that is that has to be so
awkward when it's remote uh they're
trying to do the oscars thing of like
get the shot of the person not winning
and i love that sean mary
sean murray took a sip of his beer and
then went no man's sky won because he
just didn't expect it
that was amazing because of course you'd
expect fortnite to win of course you
would but i love that but
i feel i feel like there's definitely a
lot of awkwardness in them being
required to be on call to watch
themselves not necessarily win awards
for a long time well it's even
it's even well but no it's not because
we have so we had someone
uh hannah someone who works for me um
she she
won an award uh recently and her
category
they were in a zoom call together so
it's actually it's it's like a real
award ceremony
it's nice but also like i wouldn't want
to do it like hannah was fine with it of
course but like i was
i saw it and it's like it's like being
it's like being an award show where
there's six of you around the table
and you know one of you is gonna win and
it's it's like it's more intimate
absolutely in some ways weirder than
others if i had
like been in a zoom call with the other
content creators
and i had been like hey guys like you
know congrats to everyone
uh i hope you're all doing good stuff
whoever wins this is going to be
horribly harassed
uh because gamers don't like it like it
would have been nice to have that
solidarity so like
hey well that's what they did with the
performers though like that i love that
you got to see and
a lot of people get to see that they did
that live like laura found out in real
time
um and god damn that speech was
incredible
and i was driving to to the studio when
i
was kind of what brought this up
originally was uh i was driving down
there
and i was at a stoplight and saw the
like congratulations i think craig mason
was the first one to go congratulations
last was like oh holy [ __ ] so
it won and so i said lord just went for
best performer
and uh i just called her real quick i
was like listen
i just wanted to let you know and i
hadn't seen her speech at all yet so
then i'm i'm
actually on set waiting to go up and i
was like i got a second so i watch her
speech and i'm like crying
um being able to hear just everything
that she went through man
and i i i told her in the speech that
she knew she was taking a risk with that
character she knew that people would
she did and i think we've even said it
on this she walked into that role
she walked on she auditioned first of
all laura bailey
doesn't have to audition but she did
and she walked into that role and she's
like i know
what this role is going to do i i know
what the task is i know what the job is
and she walked in head up and eyes open
she knew exactly what it was
and i i love that so much of that award
we've already talked about awards and
everything and what they mean
but there's it's not about vindication
or even validation but
man it just felt i felt good about it
um i felt good for neil for halle
for the hundreds of people that worked
on that game um for the millions of
people that played it it doesn't change
i told pam
because she said she goes game at one
game of the year
and i was like it already was they just
recognized it
it didn't all of a sudden retroactively
make it game of the year
in the same way that all of the other
games ghost of tsushima
is just as amazing today
as it was the second before they
announced game of the year
and animal crossing is also game of the
year like
yes there are so many for different
reasons yeah among us is too like 100
there are so many of them but i i
the with one of the stupidest
conversations is like yeah i disagree
with game of the year that's cool man
what's yours
you're allowed to have yeah what's your
fantastic what's yours
you don't have to argue about other
people's being different no that's why i
don't believe in snubs
there's no such thing as a snub it
doesn't change the work
i will say this i think the best acting
that i've ever done in a game
was in the last it was part two that's
that that that to me is i feel
it challenged me the most and i feel i
was it just just for what it's worth
that was my i felt really really proud
of my work
not a single nomination and it doesn't
[ __ ] change a thing
that's the beauty of awards i just in a
video but edited it out
that i felt like you should have been
nominated um
because this i've said to you before
like the stuff that you specifically did
in the last of his part two broke my
heart
so hard and as someone who talks to you
for an hour every week at no point did i
ever think
i'm detroit acting at no point did i
think that you know
i'm just like 100 like oh my god joel oh
my i sure and there's just so much of it
like
broke me and i was like should have been
nominated but then i was like
i get how this works and that
technically you were not
a quote-unquote lead like that i don't
feel right saying that but
whatever but the point is that your
impact on people your impact on me even
playing through that game
is not removed by the fact that you
weren't nominated in an award category
and that's why it literally makes no
difference yeah it makes no difference
and i
one of the reasons why um we were
discussing nominations for
the last year or the year before um
and people were talking about uh for
roger clark
and i was like this man deserves to win
surely for the fact that he had to stay
he had to
remember that character in those beats
for five
years on stage and in the booth that
level
is i had to do it was reacting for five
years straight on that one
yes and i was like just the uh
and never like consistently it's like
we've been off for six months
three months two months okay so you
remember really really hard
of the many hundreds of different
scenarios that we've been in the one
with the person that
you wanted to is is looking for is
the guy who wants to take pictures of
birds you're talking to him again
right and i was like just that guy
stayed in character
and you talked to roger clark about he
was like well troy that's what we do in
theater you know we have ourselves the
character that we love so wonderful i
just he's
although is that actually his response
because it seems like
it's the diametric opposite of theater
where you get to
every night channel that and like
chisel it and hone in on every little
atom of it the theater for him is what
has trained him for everything
roger clark is one of the finest actors
he is one of the finest actors
he's just can't say enough about that
guy
to mike bithell just one question
talking about breaking stuff as far as
physics
um well wait before you go back to that
i just the last thought on the
on the whole like the award doesn't
validate
or invalidate etc etc i don't remember
if i brought this up in the past but one
of my favorite
oscar moments uh year 2013
oscars i guess um which was would have
been like maybe six months or eight
months after the avengers came out and
when the avengers came out it you know
broke like all these box office records
and it was by far
the most earning movie of that year and
like immediately in the top
couple of all time and
so then uh someone gets up to give a to
intro a segment or bring on somebody at
the oscars and they're like
you know this last year also saw some
some major records uh broken uh the
avengers uh has
become you know the highest grossing
movie all time as enshrined
tonight by the oscars for their two
nominations for sound mixing and visual
effects or something like
that best craft services yeah like
because when you talk about a snub
no no oscar love uh
for the movie typically speaking with
occasional exceptions the bigger issue i
see with with games and
you know i was thinking about this last
night especially as someone who made an
award show this year and and i'm
probably in that business i will
probably make the same show every year
going forward for as long as i can
um until we don't need it anymore which
we are going to continue to need because
accessibility options are very
complicated
uh i i was like this show
nobody can make the show better than
keeley or they'd be making it
and better thank you that's kind of
where my head is at now it's like
it's so hard to do this stuff and i know
that like
it's it's very expensive in ways that
you would not expect like
just the expenses that just show up and
i'm like i didn't realize that that
would cost me a thousand dollars is just
like
wild and like no one can make the show
better than keeley is that why you cut
your abbey road orchestra
exactly just the 20 grand was a bit much
like i'd like to go home next year and
flights are really expensive i just have
to weigh it up
but uh the one the one thing that i
think is like
a bummer about the game awards and again
my main stance is
it doesn't matter what game you like you
like this is an industry celebration
like
calm down yes is that because video
games require so much
time the most
popular game is so much more likely to
win everything and that's why like half
half-life alex was not um brought up as
many times as it
probably would have been if it didn't
have a barrier working against it
uh you know there uh no of of
hardware and thus popularity uh sure so
because people can't
and you can't make the jury play all
these games it's not their job you can't
force them to play these games they
don't get paid to do it uh and they
don't submit things like the oscars do
and i don't want it to be like the
oscars where they pay to nominate things
and then they submit a selection
i would prefer it the way that it is uh
with the game awards and there are so
many different layers to this but
it does mean that a game that people
didn't play as much uh
ari is the big one that comes to me i
think that game's fantastic and so few
people have voted for it across the
board
because which won't get marketed as much
will it the wisps it came out
in march i think um and i love that game
one of my favorite games of the year um
and it's entirely possible that's
just subjective and it's just how i feel
about it but i think the reality is just
not many people played it
um and you can't do anything about
making the jury play games that they
don't have access to they don't have
time to play
it's just not possible i feel like that
should be a thing like it's like if you
want to be on this
it makes it more prestigious um
you have to have played the game to
finish the game but then you have to pay
them
like how do you get the jury to do that
so
do you mean play do you mean play every
game what do you mean play
all the games that are available in that
final i think
it's like a journey those are the
nominees go ahead what so i've
i've been on the bafta jury's several
times i can talk a little bit to that
me too well no you have to play them you
have to play the games
and you have to complete them okay so so
the way the game awards works
is they said after you do the list of
nominees god knows i'm about to complete
some games i didn't enjoy it
okay you don't have to do that most uh
you might be told to
i don't i don't think you want it you
you basically uh
you submit the your nominees for each
category
and you send those off and then you'll
get another form back that is
compiled of the top picks for every
category uh which is five and then you
pick your top from that
i think you can even rank oh okay but
you know lots of people as well right oh
so many is it massive the jury
massive yeah that's also part of it i
think baptism is different
because baptist chooses the nominees and
they go here are your
12. and then after membership choose the
nominees
right but what i'm saying is like the
judges don't choose the nominees
correct they then then it goes all right
here's your 12 well it's actually uh
to be it's not the nominee it's like a
short list shortly
sure
um your half-life issue wouldn't be an
issue interesting
like i'm on the i'm i i'm on the dice uh
jury each year
but they do the same way and and they do
it the same way they provide you
with the codes that the developers uh
provide to
to aias and then
basically we have a a back channel
um jury where we all argue about all of
the long-listed titles and there can be
40 or 50 of them and wait so the jury
discusses it
yes yes for like three hours
yeah i do i've done i've done i've done
supporting performance i've done
narrative a couple of years i've been i
think i did game design one year like
yeah those juries
you're basically locked in a room it's a
jury of i think it's usually like
eight people um and you
argue it out and and it's not about it's
not a demo it's it's it's well
ultimately no it is a vote within the
room
but it's and you know you keep arguing
until there's a winner yeah
and you well there's really two rounds
of voting yeah so it's like all right
everybody submit your remotes
and then if you're like remote or if
your paper is like okay so we have our
nominees and they don't tell you who it
is and you walk away that's the other
thing is you don't find out in the room
as a jury
who's won you but oh i mean to be honest
nine times out of ten you leave that
room you you yeah everybody knows
yeah do you like that the jury doesn't
talk where the game warns is concerned
that they just vote independently i do
like that um
even though i feel like it it is an
unusual approach
uh and again i still maintain nobody
could do this better than jeff or they'd
already have done it
um he obviously has the resources the
drive the know-how to make this kind of
thing happen i'm not talking
i think in america as well you've got a
much bigger
pool of people and i think as well the
other thing is there are international
people
right but but i'm saying there's just
lots of people that's what i mean is
it's with bafta
it makes sense that it's a very british
century it's also developers whereas
about americans saying the game awards
is journalists and developers or is it
just journalists
right that's kind of like the super
impressed right that's kind of like a
difference between the academics
golden globes yeah golden globes so like
but that's that's why
i feel like there's different awards
like bafta typically nominates different
people
oh yeah and golden joysticks whatever
they do
uh so like we have our golden globes our
spirit awards our oscars we
we've got these different uh people's
choice awards and we've we've got the
different kind of awards
um that we've talked about this before
the the beauty of them and
the reason why i want there to be more
award shows is
it's a different case for alana's i just
pointed down at alana
uh actually accurate nailed it
um because
for my from my pov it was correct for
the first time ever
i want people to be who are typically
not recognized in this industry or or
things that are not by and large
popularized in this industry to be made
popular
um the accessibility awards
the purpose of it is to inform people
and encourage developers to
add more accessibility options into
their games that is the purpose of it
um and you know that was a really
interesting process it's like we
our jury was entirely made up of
disabled gamers who could speak to each
of the categories um so those are the
people who who voted and it's a small
pool
uh was the biggest problem that we had
it is a small pool
of people who have not worked on a show
like this before so some of the
nominations in some cases
um like red dead redemption was
nominated for
for an accessibility award that it
doesn't have um
for an option it does not have because
people just kind of misremembered
so there was like this weird thing of me
being like okay ethically i do not want
any part of this
but i have to disqualify things if they
are not
applicable to the category because
somebody made a mistake so that it was
very complicated and that's the thing
that i need to do next year is get a
bigger pool of
of players which is obviously difficult
when it's uh disabled game isn't it it
can be so small but outreach is
certainly a thing that we need to try to
to do a better job of um but that was
how our jury worked was they just
nominated whatever they wanted and then
the thing that got the most
nominations was what we picked as our
winner for the most part a lot of ties
though too actually
so then it was like a matter of re-going
through and getting extra votes and all
that stuff it's
it's super complicated i think the thing
i like about the jury
talking sorry i cut you off their
apologies i think the thing i like about
the jury talking is that you can have
um advocates and i think this is also
kind of the weakness of it i think
that's why it's one of the reasons as
troy says that there is a
there is a unique difference to the the
different ways these work is when you
have advocates in the room you can have
weird games win you can have a game
though i've been on
a couple of juries and i don't remember
if i'm allowed to say which but there
was i can think of one jury i was on
which was i think it was the game design
bafta a couple of years ago and
obviously all the big hitters were in
there
and there was one specific very strange
indie game that no one had played
and because we were a force to play
every game and because beta was a strong
advocate in the room
i think that one won and it was because
it was
weird and interesting and creative and
probably that award
meant much more than award number eight
to you know an established hit
not that there's not a place for the
other kind as well but it was
it's cool to have uh the opportunity for
something
niche to break through i think that's
you know that's that's
that's a that's a nice thing in some
rooms but it shouldn't be the case in
all of them and
i like what troy says that there are
different awards that serve to do
different things differently yes
there isn't one show to rule them all it
doesn't have to be
like watch the one you like i had a um
an experience like that i got
i got rather inexplicably asked to be on
the jury for best score of the
irish film academy awards this year
um okay no idea what do you know about
film scores
well what do i know about irish film
scores
um but they sent me a bunch of screeners
of their
of their long list and i i had not heard
of
i think a single one of these films um
and i watched them all and then we and
it was the jury process just like
we're talking about and i went in there
like with my list sort of figured out
and my list completely changed as a
result of
conversations of our discussion and one
of the biggest reasons why was that
you know there was like a few
you know english folks on the panel a
few irish folks i was kind of the token
american
um and but there were two different
films that dealt with the irish famine
and they had the opposite tone of each
other one was
very dour and heavy and one was very
almost fantastical
um and and surreal in a way and
um the irish friend of mine she's a
conductor
primarily uh who she she made this whole
big
overture about how she said you know to
to irish people
talking about the famine is kind of like
germans talking about the holocaust it
extends a long shadow across many
generations and it and she said you know
the population to this day is still
less than what it was and you would
admire the feminists
and well and she and i knew i knew its
historical significance in very broad
generic terms
but to hear her say that the way the
courageousness with which this film
tackled this subject in a way that's so
unexpected
and by bringing such a contemporary
aesthetic to the score and she made this
whole big
um appeal to say this is what because
when i first heard it i thought oh
that's interesting you know that sort of
novel and she was like
it's more than that let me show let me
tell you some things that you don't know
and it really made me see it in a whole
new way and i thought wow these
filmmakers are operating in a dimension
that i was not aware of
and their composers respectively and
i it blew me away and it was such a it
was such a
an enlightening experience that i i
really came away from it like i'm a
better
composer i think from being on this jury
because it really made me think
in a more broad way i didn't just fill
out a nomination card you know like i
really
because because she was like no here's
why you're wrong and then basically
demonstrated
why i was wrong i thought well hell i
mean i i
cannot refute that that sounds awesome i
think my my only issue which doesn't
seem entirely related to what you're
saying with juries is
that in some cases i feel like whoever
is the most
convincing debater could just turn a
room
by being well it depends how competent
the room is
if the rooms if the room is a hundred
people of various
skill levels and whatever and various
kind of backgrounds yes
i think when it's a small room of peers
there's just that baseline level of
respect
and and i think generally why i have
noticed doing those juries for a while
is
the people who are disrespectful of
their peers and would try and railroad a
conversation
they don't tend to come back in the
second year they tend to be invited back
you know i think that's completely
accurate
there's you end up with subjective
results it's not going to get you your
objectively what was the objectively
best
thing whatever that's important but
there's subjects
you get really interesting subjective
take it's fun it can lead to a more
personality yeah i
um i i had discounted overcooked because
i played it and i was like
i don't like it that graves rats game
too
but did you play with other people yeah
that's why
yeah i didn't i played it single i was
like this game sucks
and i got into the room they're like you
didn't play it the way it was supposed
to be designed and that actually gave
birth to a whole other conversation was
like if a game has a single player
experience that is subpar
two a multiplayer experience should it
still be nominated or should it be like
then don't include that like we got into
like really uh interesting conversations
about it
but it's something that i believe that
and again
we're saying this multiple times that
doesn't mean that everybody should
operate this way but the beauty of
i went back and played over coach
whether the people was like oh this
thing is actually a lot of fun
um so those conversations about people
who are judging things
and looking through a certain lens can
actually be better for games like the
case of mike um here's a game you guys
may have not played
lucas pope you know is is is a perfect
example of that is like have you heard
of this guy
like and he's the band that the other
bands like to go see play
so he's like he's like the yard birds of
that's a weird reference for people to
understand but okay we've gone so far in
one direction now can we circle back to
uh i can circle back to something
because i also have like two minutes and
then i gotta
bounce um uh mike bithell was right
mike
you said this on the show a while ago if
uh remake remaster is announced it's
because they're testing the waters to
see if people want
a few months later 100 correct exactly
not a great title but damn that trailer
holy [ __ ] i lost my mind just perfect
dark more about anything which sucks
because i was barely paying attention i
need to re-watch it because i was like
trying to get my audio to work and like
setting things up and then i was like
wait wait he just say
joanna doc oh my god here's what i don't
understand though and
i wanted to ask this question before
most anticipated game which is just a
weird category but i get it
biggest marketing budget yeah all right
well okay
i hadn't said a lot of studios in there
all right am i am i just weird
what did you say huh i hadn't heard of
eldon ring at all
oh um
is from south georgia martin but that's
one of the ones that
uh i don't think it's unusual that
you've not heard of that
it is one of those games that has not
been heavily marketed but is one of the
um gamer culture beloved right now
like mysterious announced it last night
yeah
like that's that's how it felt like that
is like where it was e3 wasn't it
yeah yeah yeah it was it was it was an
hour stages ago um it leaked like the
day before wasn't it
it leaked like the from software are
doing a george rr martin that was like a
new story
or something about from software but i
didn't remember like george r martin and
by the way i don't know
if i need a game by george well that's
why
the joke right now is that it's going to
take troy there are ten stringing songs
in the first
hour it's based on war of the roses
it's great i also to to to
austin wintry did in your opinion
is there something um that final fantasy
vii remake did
that um from a music standpoint that was
uh i have not done a d it was so okay
i thought goes to sushima should have i
mean perfect demonstration of my biggest
complaint
uh and i saw this echoed across
basically the entirety of my colleagues
in the game audio the
the i am not a fan of
the sort of ranking
of categories like if you can't fit a
category into your show
don't have that category in my
estimation if i were
mr keely in producing my own show and
you're 100 correct alana in your
assessment of like
you know if someone else would have done
it and you could easily throw it back to
me as
well we look forward to attending your
award show you're still allowed to have
opinions
but i i i am not a fan there's a few
things i'm not a fan of i'm not a fan
of um
they they did music as a pre-show
toss-away category um and there were a
bunch of other categories as well just
like okay we're just going to blitz
through
here like at one point he just kind of
read off like here's three more
categories
congrats to the winners moving on to the
next trailer and i'm like
is it oh no is it a is it an award show
celebrating the
we discussed this exact thing last year
because they did it with performance
last year
and yeah i know uh which i fully agree
with you austin i i think it's in poor
taste
um but uh i believe the reason that they
did it
last year which could be the same as
this year is they did it for categories
where
the nominees were not able to give
acceptance speeches
where all of them were not able to well
that's definitely not the case for music
because all the nominees had
to pre-tape uh acceptance speeches and
it was shown
as part of the pre-show and then what
cracks me up further
is using an orchestra in london
uh to in my opinion
you know lauren who was conducting and
producing it he's he and i are friendly
i
have nothing but absolute respect for
him and and
um and uh you know we're on good terms
and and he's
had the most amazing career uh
uh sort of rise the last ten years or so
um
and and deservedly so the guys the guy's
awesome um
and um we had some friendly jousting
back in the day when
journey and assassin's creed 3 were kind
of nominated against each other
repeatedly
and but i
i thought you know
to to rearrange so heavily uh both the
hades music
and do maternal music as part of the
overture the sort of game of the year
nominees
to make a musical declaration about the
game of the year nominees
and to to change them so far
from what they are as a way to
flatten it so that every piece kind of
sounds the same
i was like boy boy i i'm not on board
with that and and on top of that
the fact that that the the orcas they
they go to the trouble
to have an orchestra at abbey road no
less it's like which i in a way i'm like
that's cool you're already you're
embracing the remote nature of the award
show so why not just [ __ ] go to abbey
road
i'm sure all the union musicians in los
angeles were royally pissed about that
and you know it's a global marketplace
there's
that but um but um
um but uh so you know fair enough i
i'm not i i enjoy the pt barnum aspect
of jeff keely and like
putting on a spectacle to me that's show
business like
totally get it i think it's awesome
actually i admire someone who really can
put on a show
but i'm like you have the ingredients
right there and you're
and you're like but music itself as
a subcomponent of games is
a pre-show sort of quick mention and
then
no honoring of that in this thing that
we've already built
musically i to me i don't understand the
calculation i saw a lot of people
in my community going you know way to
make
music look so unimportant compared to
other categories
especially highlighted by the fact that
you went so
far down the music rabbit hole in other
ways
and i get it i'm like yeah i don't
disagree but how do you feel about final
fantasy vii winning
[Laughter]
well done well done i completely forgot
that
[Music]
um
[Music]
i i completely lost the threat i feel
like you've said
negative things about that final fantasy
7
is one of the most beloved game scores
of all time
and what i and and what i couldn't i
haven't
spent a hell of a lot of time uh
learning about what went into the remake
musically
i just know that for for me i i i loved
how much
the ghost of sushi melee used music i
just i don't i don't
i don't i didn't i didn't listen to the
to the the scores why it was why i was
asking
it's i think that was doom and town very
good it's do maternal is also very good
to hades is also very good the last of
us part two is also very good like to me
indeed
to me in my taste uh final fantasy vii
was
far and away the weakest of the
nominated scores um because
i i saw it as first off when i listened
to the music i was like it's a bunch of
big orchestral music done with samples
and i'm like given how much money
they've spent on this thing that's hard
for me to wrap my head around
that's what i remember you saying when
the game came out and but also i'm like
this game it is it is
like to use the oscars as an analogy
um the two the fellowship of the ring
won the oscar in 2001
uh from score which everybody saw coming
even though i personally would have
voted for
spielberg's uh movie ai uh but um
uh but then the two towers then
yes perfect
are you are you going to the part where
he feels john williams got screwed
i know but what's scary is i no one saw
him pull that book
he just happened to have it no what do
you do mike bethel just pulled out a
steven spielbeck book wow
um so the funny thing was that the two
towers was
deemed ineligible the following year for
the oscars
because of significant reuse of existing
material because it was this
thematic score that had you know like
hey there's the hobbit thing again theme
again there's the thing for the ream
the theme for the ring again um and then
uh so the idea was like no a score must
be 100 new and original which of course
in a thematic
light motific score automatically means
you've disqualified yourself by virtue
of doing your job the right way
well fair enough awards are arbitrary
the thing that was bizarre was that then
return of the king
with no change in the awards won the
next year
so he he won two oscars and the middle
one was disqualified so when i but
through that lens i look at final
fantasy vii remake and i go is this
actually
substantially new or we're basically
going back to 1997
and going by the way we just want to
remind you that this was awesome then
and it's awesome again
and i'm like yeah i now here's the thing
maybe it's 90 new music from the
original
uh i know that there's the game itself
is substantially new relative to the
original yeah
right uh and so maybe it is i it's one
of those i just haven't spent enough
time it just didn't interest me enough
uh you know it's just not my thing so i
i don't know but i had an immediate
raised eyebrow of like
are we basically re-awarding what is
already
one of the most beloved scores ever
written for a video game
like transgender generation i think that
is exactly what happened
that's the inevitable outcome of a large
vote for a category right if you've got
if you remake citizen kane you're gonna
go
to yeah if you go well especially if you
go to game journalists and
ask them like what do you love they're
gonna tell you final fantasy 67
right yeah this is what it always this
is what always happens with the oscars
too where the music branch chooses the
nominees the music branch are
invited well all members of the academy
are invite only but the music branch are
obviously
professionals at a high level there are
people who have what in fact gustavo
centalia told me personally
he had to win the oscar twice to be
invited in
to actually be a voting person in the
academy like
so it's a selective operation but the
thing
is the general academy chooses the
winner so you can always pick
who's going to win best music because
they will
probably have five relatively well
picked scores generally speaking
but it's always whichever one is most
likely to win best picture
is almost guaranteed to win best score
because the
general body of the academy doesn't know
anything about music so the informed
voters choose the nominees and then turn
it loose and i think that
kind of feels like what happened with
final fantasy
very quickly um
pc or ps5 for cyberpunk oh my god
pc oh i don't know that ps5 is
performing badly but the game that i'm
playing
beautiful stunningly beautiful on a 3080
with raytracer there's a lot of
characters
you just got that 3080 so that's that's
so pretty but then i'm seeing people
what they're playing on xbox one
and ps4 and i'm like we are not playing
the same game
it's crazy i don't know that ps5 is is
uh
that i don't imagine it's as bad but my
gosh the difference is
all right i saw this there's not a
bespoke version for ps5 right it's
people
are playing ps4 it is you're still
playing the ps4 version correct but that
i think it's getting an upgrade i almost
want to tell people
to just wait to play the game like i get
that you want to play it right now i'm
having a fantastic time
um lots of stuff floating that's
definitely an issue and i've had crashes
too actually even on my that to me
like that's not a bug that's a feature i
don't care about the floating at all
i think it's great yeah um all right i'm
gonna do that
um you guys are awesome good day sir
congrats on the video game winning
awards
and also also just and to i already
texted troy this
last night but uh the authenticity
of what you
he to the two of you shared uh
was for me the highlight of the show uh
of of
of shining a light on on what goes into
making these characters
uh you know to me just the authenticity
it didn't it didn't read i i felt like i
was no longer watching the game awards
for a second
and i was getting this real moment of
humanity and i say that i know i'm not
objective when it comes to
anything yeah i fully acknowledge and i
love the game and i'm
nothing but admiration of naughty dog
and neil and i and there's a million
reasons why i'm
this not an objective assessment but it
still stood out tremendously for me
as like oh i'm not being sold something
and i and i don't want to sound super
cynical but i just i'm very much aware
of that the whole time i'm watching
and then pause here's something
that showed that these people really
cared quite a lot about what they were
making
okay pause that back to the salesmanship
there was if thank you uh when when jeff
approached me he was like hey
um are you cool we we've got eddie
vetter and eddie
i think was originally going to be live
to do that
um and then just circumstances being
what they are wasn't able to he's like
would you be cool with
with uh presenting and i was like yes
let me check with neil i just want to
make sure because
i just i already knew how much that
meant to neil
and so he's like you know what we'll
have a script phrase like
can i write my own he's like yeah you've
done it every other year before you've
done this so sure go for it
and so i said i want to write this with
neil and make sure he was cool with that
and
and what was most important to me is not
so much about
me playing that song but
that moment was crafted by neil and
the the fact that neil that the fact
that joel played guitar was something
that
neil gave to me to make
joel and i put a little bit of me into
joel
and the whole comment about ashley being
an astronaut that's true
she's like i don't know astronaut and
and said it as if like i would have gone
into sales
and so that's where that comes from
ellie so that's that's a little bit of
troy a little bit of ashley
in joel and ellie and the beauty of that
moment is is him saying this is a song
that i play for my daughter every night
and the fact that
pearl jam is his favorite band eddie
vetter is just like an idol to him
and the fact that that was that was a
win for naughty dog yes but it was also
a win specifically for
neil and after all the [ __ ] that he's
gone through uh
for the last several years and
specifically this year for that game
uh he even texted me back he's like do
you think it's too much about me i was
like
absolutely not calm down so i was i was
great to shine a light
on on him for that moment because that
moment exists
um and it was such a moment of sincerity
because jeff allowed me to
point that out and that moment is
sincere inherently
uh because of what neil gave to ashley
and i
so with that i bid you guys
have a great weekend i actually also
have to go so maybe we just wrap up the
show here uh
i technically never got to do the intro
so thank you everyone for watching play
watch listen i'm milana that's troye
baker video game actor
that's mike bithell video game director
that's awesome with your video game
composer
uh i just want to let everyone know
ahead of time it's not next week but we
are skipping
the week of christmas so there will be
no episode on the 25th
um so that we can kind of have a week
off but they'll still be you know our
last episode for the year will be the
18th
yeah um so we will see you next week bye